welcome to welcome back peter to the
second part of
the simulation mythology tutorial thanks
for coming back
thank you very much so this is round two
of simulation methodology and overview
so what i'm going to talk about uh
in this session is uh what
i refer to and what many other people
have now can refer to as efficiency
improvement techniques
but if you've read the modical low and
simulation literature you'll often hear
the term variance reduction
methods over introduction techniques
this is basically
the same set of ideas but expressed in a
somewhat
broader view and
i'll talk about the sort of slight uh
difference in emphasis between variance
reduction and efficiency improvement a
bit
later in this lecture then i'm going to
talk about some specific efficiency
improvement techniques control variants
on random numbers important sampling
there are many many other
such methods available within the
monoclonal simulation
communities uh and i'll talk about
gradient estimation that obviously uh
relates strongly to the world of
stochastic optimization and i'll finish
with some
quick discussion about stochastic
optimization
all right so efficiency improvement
techniques uh
you know we're all thinking about
algorithms uh oftentimes we'll have a
choice as to which algorithm
we uh may wish to use to compute a
particular quantity let's say
alpha in the context of uh
simulation of monte carlo so it could be
that we have
algorithm number one that gives rise to
a sequence of iterates alpha n
converging
with probability one let's say to alpha
and the second
algorithm that gives rise to some beta
ends
and then we want to use obviously the
algorithm that converges faster that's
computationally more efficient and uh
you know as we discussed in the last
lecture
it's standard within the modic parallel
and simulation communities to use limit
theorems to
study rates of convergence questions so
this is not a community that tends to
focus on hard earned balance
and uh in this setting let's just assume
that we have
central limit theorems for both
algorithm one and algorithm
two and let's assume that they're of the
same type that you sort of
often see in the world of monochrome
namely square root convergence
with a normal distribution on the right
hand side so
algorithm number one uh alpha n minus
alpha when scaled by square root of n
converges to a normal zero one with
standard deviation
uh sigma one sitting out in front of
them and similarly for beta and
of course as we saw in the last lecture
these two
uh limit theorems are asserting that
alpha and
beta and converge to their respective
limits and square root convergence rate
and with uh proportionality constant
sort of measuring
the incidence dependent
convergence rate characterized by sigma
1 and sigma 2.
so if we uh just unpack
those two limit theorems and they
suggest
that uh alpha n and beta n for large n
look like
normal random variables having mean
alpha but with different variances in
one case in case of alpha n sigma one
squared over n in case of
beta n sigma 2 squared over n and
it seems quite natural if you have a
limit theorem of that type
to choose algorithm 1 over algorithm 2
if the variance corresponding to
algorithm one is smaller than
the corresponding variance for algorithm
two
so this approach to choosing and
constructing
estimators is based on variance and when
we
try to construct an estimator that has
smaller variance
than the current algorithms variance
we are said to be implementing a
variance reduction of some kind
and the class of algorithms are known as
variance reduction techniques
so again if you search under bridge
reduction technique within the world of
simulation
in the world of monte carlo uh you'll
come to an enormous
range of different ideas that have been
developed over the years depending on
the
uh communities that are involved yes
just a quick uh note of course this
assumes that
uh the cost of simulation is kind of
similar
across these two methods right because i
could use metal advan and simulate more
and
reduce variance that way that's kind of
like city
well i thank you so much for saying that
because you've set me up for my next
slide
okay yeah all right each iteration of
alpha n could be much more costly than
an iteration of the second
uh algorithm so you really need to look
at something that takes into account the
work required to compute
one uh estimator versus the other
so that you can do by accumulating the
total computer time request which
compute alpha n and correspondingly
beta m so called t one of n the total
computer term for s
estimator one t two and the total
computer time
estimator two to compute alpha and beta
m
and then uh you can look at something
that
is uh objectively
uh an appropriate
metric on which to look at quality of
estimators
namely let's look at the total computer
time
budget c and let's look at within a
given computer budget
seeing which of the two algorithms
behaves best
so in view of that perspective
we want to look at the estimators that
are available after c units of computer
kind of been expended
and of course the number the the
value of n that we'll get to within a
computer budget c
may be a random variable itself
uh particularly for the algorithm i and
i have c will be
the maximum n that we're able to get to
within
computer budget c now you can look at
the
uh estimator available after having
expanded c unification time that will be
alpha of c for algorithm one beta super
algorithm
two uh and study the convergence rate of
those two quantities so
uh in many settings there would be
some kind of law of large numbers for
nifc
the total number of iterations that you
were able to complete
within cu of computer time
and uh uh
so for example a lot of large numbers
might say that ni of c divided by c
converges to
some positive constant lambda i so
lambda i is basically the rate at which
we compute
iterations per unit of computer time
and then it's typically relatively
straightforward
to convert the two
uh limit theorems that we developed
earlier in which the time index
was number of iterations that doesn't
take into account this
issue having to do with the cost per
iteration of one algorithm versus the
added
now we're doing something that is work
normalized
and uh those two limiters now
uh convert to limit theorems
involving alpha c and beta c
and now we see on the right hand side a
more
complicated uh variance parameter
having to do with the product of uh
lambda one
there's a minus one half and sigma one
whereas negative one
corresponding leader estimators too
so based on having c units of computer
time available
we obviously want to choose the
estimator which is better and now we
would choose estimator number one over
estimator number two
if uh its corresponding variance
parameter
is smaller than the second one and the
case where the uh estimators are
obtained by just
taking sample averages of iid quantities
that's the sort of
plain vanilla monte carlo context
so then the uh alpha n would just be
let's say
an average of some w i's
and then just to be clear in that
context
sigma 1 would just have been the
variance of sigma 1 squared we're just
in the variance of w1
and lambda 1 inverse that would just be
the expected
amount of computer time tau 1 required
to generate the random variable w1
so this figure of merit down here in
this context
would be the product of the expected
time
to regenerate a
w random variable multiplied by the
variance
of a w random variable and then you
would choose the algorithm that has the
smallest product
so you can see from this analysis that
uh
when you look at a work normalized
analysis as we have here
you don't necessarily want to go for the
smaller variance estimator you want to
look at the product
there are actually even some settings
where you can get such a significant
reduction in the expected time required
to generate uh the random object
w that you're willing to
uh use a w that has a slightly or
somewhat higher variance
because this thing's reduced so much
that even if the variance goes up
somewhat
uh you're comfortable with them so what
we really should be focusing
on is not variance reduction but uh
reducing this work normalized quantity
uh and as a consequence rather if you
think about variance reduction we really
should be thinking about efficiency
improvement
by which we mean trying to reduce this
product now
uh one important distinction between the
world of simulation
and the world of statistics is the
following
or both uh literatures
and both uh sets of ideas focused
on using samples to
estimate things but there's a very very
important difference between statistics
and simulation a lot of statistics
you sample because you don't know the
underlying population
of course in the world of simulation we
have algorithms available to actually
generate samples from the given
population
so we may not be able to write down
easily the probability distribution of
the particular quantity that we're
trying to compute
but we know it implicitly because we
have an algorithm that generates
random variants from that particular
distribution
so in the world of statistics one sample
because we don't know p in the world of
monte carlo
all that you're really doing as we
discussed in the last lecture
is you're taking samples basically as a
computational vehicle for computing a
high dimensional
integral basically the computational
vehicle for computing
and expected value so the world of
simulation
is really a class of numerical methods
that are intended to
offer efficient computation of expected
values and probabilities
that means in the simulation context
that in principle
we know the underlying probability
distribution that we're working with
and as a consequence we can try to
leverage the
uh knowledge that we have that
underlying club redistribution
to try to obtain efficiency improvements
so pretty much all of the efficiency
improvements that
you are able to generate within the
world of monte carlo
what you're effectively doing is using
problem structure
that is built into the particular
computational environment that you're
dealing with
to improve the rate of convergence so
the more problem structure we have
available
the better uh you should be able to
reduce variance
that is one of the things that makes
this a particularly interesting part of
the world of
simulation the world of monte carlo is
trying to be creative with how you
uh develop and how you exploit
particular
problem structures all right so
let me talk about uh start with one of
the most simple of
all their introduction methods but one
that was very very general
applies in many different contexts and
often can be
quite uh powerful quite useful
uh when appropriately applied
so again we're going to start off with
the goal of trying to compute a
particular expected value we're going to
compute the expected
value that's every random variable w
and suppose that we have some random
variable z with a known expectation now
it's always the case in any simulation
context that there are
many random variables lying around for
which you have known expectation
so in particular we all know that
the randomness that we use in a
simulation environment typically derives
from underlying
uniform random variables and we
certainly know what the expected value
of a uniform random variable
is so we have quite obviously
lots of uh input quantities that go into
our simulation
that have no unexpected values
so assuming now that we have a random
variable z
available to us it has a known
expectation we can
center that random variable z subtract
off its
expected value because we know what
expected value of z is
that gives us a random variable c
that'll call the control
area you control the random variable
now you can look at the random variable
w of lambda which is
given by the original w minus some
constant
times the control c and we see that
if you look at the expected value of
this quantity well c has mean zero
because
c is the centered z and as a consequence
uh expected value of w has exact points
frankly of w lambda has exactly the same
expected value as w itself so you
haven't changed
the expected value whatsoever by
subtracting off lambda c
but by subtracting up lambda c
potentially we can
judiciously use the correlation between
w and c to get a variance reduction
so let's see how that works
if we compute the variance of w of
lambda we get the variance of w minus
two times lambda times the covariance
plus squared times the variance
that's quadratic and lambda easy to
minimize and the minimizing lambda stars
given by the covariance
between w and the controls
c itself divided by the variance of c
when you plug in that minimizing value
of lambda star
it turns out that the minimizing
variance is exactly the variance of w
that we
started with that you would have had if
you didn't apply a control variable
times 1 minus rho squared where rho is
the
coefficient of correlation between w and
c
and this says of course the closer
that row is either plus one or minus one
the larger average reduction you'll get
by applying this particular
uh methodology so if you can get a
strong correlation whether it be
positive or negative just so long as
they
uh correlate strongly with one another
uh control varies can give a very
significant
degree of variance reduction
now of course uh in practice
since we don't know the expected value
of w we don't know
the variance of w we don't know the
covariance between w
and c so this lambda star is
unknown in general but as with many
things in the world of monte carlo
we can internally estimate these
parameters from the sample itself in
particular
we all know how to estimate the
variance of a random variable c through
its sample variance
and there's a corresponding sample
covariance that can be used to estimate
the population covariance between w and
c
and if you plug in those sample
estimates
then we get a quantity lambda hat n
and then we can imagine using the
estimator w
by n minus lambda hat n times c bar
n as our estimator of the
quantity alpha and if we
apply this particular
control variates uh approach
we would expect since very enlarged
since lambda hat n converges to lambda
star
almost surely as n goes to infinity for
large sample sizes we might hope that
its variance behaves pretty much the
same
as if you had known the correct value of
lambda star from the beginning and
indeed that's what happens in this
particular cases
there's going to be a central limit term
for this quantity
and the central limit theorem for this
random variable look exactly the same as
the central limit theorem
in the case that you had known the
optimal control parameter from the
beginning
so uh as a consequence this is a
uh a relatively straightforward method
to apply
and you can get significant variance
reductions uh in many cases
it's typically close to being
and when you put together a simulation
it doesn't cost much to collect both
the sample mean of the ci's along with
the sample mean of the w
i's and computing the
lambda hat and at the end is also
relatively costless relative to actually
generating paths of the underlying
system itself
so oftentimes this is a pretty uh
cheap thing to implement they will
pay very little cost in terms of
increase in the
computation time and it'll be more than
enough for introduction to make this
work grow
now the control variance method that i
just described
is a control variant scheme involving a
single control but we could have a
vector of controls as well
and then the lambda becomes a
vector of control coefficients that have
to be optimally estimated
and again that is relatively doable you
do run into
problems as you would expect if you
choose the number of controls to be too
large
then basically you
will not have enough data available to
accurately estimate the covariance
structure
and you could get some uh
bad things happening as a consequence
but if you
limit the number of controls that you
use to ones that are
have strong correlations the
vector-valued version of this algorithm
can also work quite
well and quite effectively so i'd like
to
uh illustrate this idea in the context
of markov chains i'm going to
introduce another idea
uh related to so-called martingale
controls
is something that uh i looked at with a
phd student of mine shane henderson
and shawn has also been involved in
doing research on this
particular class of ideas so
let me just illustrate this uh
methodology
in the context of trying to compute an
expected infinite horizon discounted
reward
so uh we're going to try to compute this
expected value
expected value starting from state x and
of course
if i look at uh this expected value as a
function of state
x that gives me a function u star that
depends on the particular starting state
x and uh probably we all know
that this u star satisfies a particular
system of linear equations
in particular if we write u as a column
vector in which the x
entry is u star of x
then u that column vector satisfies is
equal to the reward vector
r plus the discount factor the minus
alpha times p u or p
is the transition matrix of the markov
shade
now it turns out that
this random variable m n if i look at
this as a function of
n uh this is
what is it with the right hand side is
basically the
sum of the discounted rewards up to time
n minus one
plus a discounted down uh version
of u star of x n and you start with x n
is basically the cost to go
for the reward to go from the random
state xn that we're in at time
n and this mn turns out to be a
martingale
so what is a martingale martingale of
course is a sequence of random variables
having the property
that its conditional expectation of time
n plus one given the history of the
chain up to time
n is exactly the value of the martingale
time
n so that is uh
defines what we call a martingale and of
course one
implication of that is that if i take
the expected value of both sides of this
equation i can conclude that the
expected value of m n
plus n and m plus one is equal to the
expected value of
m n in other words iron gels have the
property that the mean doesn't change
over time
so marketing guilds were first
used in conjunction with exploring
gambling systems
and those would correspond to the
fortune of a gambler and a fair game
uh his or her fortune would have
no tendency to either increase or
decrease in expectation over time
so that's martin gale and of course uh
the consequence of this is that uh the
mean doesn't change as a function of
n so m n minus m zero has expected value
zero
so that is a potential control that we
can use
according to the control variables
velocity that we discussed
earlier
now if i put lambda equals 1 in this
particular example
and i look at w minus lambda c infinity
so
c infinity is m infinity minus m zero
m infinity is this quantity
right here with n input set equal to
infinity
and with n set equal to infinity this
discount factor here makes the second
quantity zero
and this first quantity is just the
infinite sum so uh
m infinity is exactly equal to this
infinite sum
up here and m zero m zero is just u star
of x zero itself so
we're looking at c infinity was just
this infinite sum
minus the u star value at
the initial state
so when you look at w and you subtract
lambda times c infinity with lambda
equals one you just get that
u star of x itself u star of x
of course is deterministic so
we actually get variance of w of lambda
with this choice of lambda
equal to zero so this is a zero variance
method
it would be great if you could actually
apply this in practice but of course you
can't apply this in practice because
you don't know the u star of x function
after all these r of x function is what
we're actually trying to compute with
this simulation
but what this suggests uh and this is a
philosophy that
we will uh use at least one more time
in this talk is if you don't know
something at least
hope that there you can find for example
an approximation
to that you start and use that instead
so uh so
what this analysis suggests is uh
let's try to find a u-tilde that's a
good approximation to use star
if we can do that then we're going to
use
this martingale instead involving the
utility
in place of u star involving an fire
tilde instead of the
original reward function and what is the
r tilde
yar tilde is just what it needs to be in
order
for uh utilita
to satisfy the same type of linear
system that we
discussed earlier for
uh the original problem
which means in particular the utility
function can again be uh represented can
then be viewed as being the infinite
horizon expected value
uh discounted against uh
rewards that are no longer given by the
original rewards
r of x that are given by this modified
rewards
are told of x for r tilde is given by
this quantity all right so
that gives us a suggestive way of using
a good approximation
if the approximation is good then it
would i would hope
that you can get very strong variance
reductions because we know that if you
chose exactly the right choice of u star
you'd actually get a variance zero
well in practice obviously using
approximation we're not going to vary in
zero but we hope that we get something
that
is significantly reduced relative to the
standard plain vanilla in this community
all right so that's a an illustration of
controlled variants
and uh it's an application
to the um in the context of markup
change in particular
uh in the setting of uh martingale that
controls
by the way this approach that we used
here to construct
a control variable uh applies in many
many
other settings as well not just infinite
horizon discovered work but basically
any expected value of probability in the
world of markov chains for which there
is a linear system of equations
that defines that expected value or that
probability
that would be something that would be
amenable to the same kind of martingale
idea
to establish various reductions
all right so let's turn now to another
uh
common various reduction method in fact
the method of
common random numbers and uh
let's talk about uh how that would apply
in the setting in which we have for
example two policies that you want to
compare
and policy number one gives rise to a
random variable
that i'll call w1 and policy number two
gives rise to a
random variable or called w2 we're
trying to compare the expected value of
w1
this is effective value of w2 of course
in doing the comparison we'd like to
look at uh is expected to have w1 bigger
than expected value of w2
we'd probably also like to know the
magnitude of that difference
so we're trying to compute the
difference between
kappa 1 and capital two capital high
being expected by your w
play um
just for the previous method uh multiple
of us are wondering about so if
p is i mean you pressuredly have a
simulated
markov chain but in the definition of
r tilde you have to apply p to u
theodore
which if you have a high dimensional
state spacer like life state space in
general
uh i mean like how do you calculate this
art order
uh you would need to know the values of
artillery and attractory to
be able to calculate this very
introduced
estimate uh so what do what what shall
we do
like what what should we be thinking
about what's happening here
how do we make this a functional
procedure
so there are settings where you can do
this quite readily
so uh you know the markov chains
in which uh
we have a stochastic recursion of this
form where the zi's
have a nice well-known distribution and
it wouldn't be hard in that context to
compute
this quantity right it'll just be in
that setting to
call it a little bit more
[Music]
has also some nice analytical form and
the distribution has some nice
sometimes right so in some modeling
context for example when you're using
simulation context of
performance modeling
um
there we go then it would often be the
case that you would
know exactly what the g function would
be and you'd know exactly what the
distribution of z would be
and this wouldn't be a hard thing to do
now the reinforcement learning
context where you don't have this type
of explicit structure
you're absolutely right this is a
significantly harder thing to implement
in that context
and i would say that's probably an open
research question
as to whether this can be practically
useful
in that setting okay yeah
it's good it's it's very good to know
that that this is how the the fields
uh kind of looking at similar problems
but slightly different settings and then
different things make sense
right in some settings
doing this calculation is quite viable
in other settings
and i think you pointed out uh you know
it is the case that uh that
uh i think in the rl context this would
be a harder thing significantly harder
thing to think through how you could
implement this effectively
thanks perspective thanks great great
question
okay so let's talk about to go back to
the economy on the numbers
issue we're trying to compare
uh two different stochastic uh
models of course responding to two
different policies
and obviously in estimating alpha the
most natural thing to do is just to
estimate
uh the uh expected value for
policy one through a sample average of
correspondingly
also for the second policy now one thing
that's important to recognize is there's
no reason that we need to use
exactly the same sample size as n1 and
m2 and comparing these two systems
and when you make that observation make
that realization that leads you into the
world of what
would be called stratified sampling so
how much uh
computational effort you want to devote
the
policy one versus policy two but you'd
imagine somehow that that would have
something to do
with uh how variable
uh w1s versus w2
and indeed there's a optimal
choice for how much sampling you should
do of one
stratum versus the other of system one
versus system two and uh
it turns out that the optimal sample
size
scales uh in proportion by the way not
to the variance but in proportion to the
standard deviation
so you ought to choose ni proportional
to
uh lambda either minus one-half turn
signal pi of course
and one plus m2 has to be equal to the
computational budget that
uh you have so that's uh
efficiency improvement technique one
efficiency improvement technique two is
what
people call the method of common random
numbers
so in the first efficiency equivalent
technique
you're free to use different sample
sizes because all of the samples that
we use for
estimator 1 are independent of those for
estimator 2 and since these are
completely decoupled calculations
i can run a bigger sample size for one
than for the other
but another thing that you could do is
you could pair up the
w1 simulations with the w2 simulations
and then try to
correlate the w1s and w2s from each
successive set of experiments
now you'd have to choose the sample
sizes equal because you're pairing up w1
and w2 in every
experiment that you do in every
simulation that you do
now you try to construct a joint
distribution supporting both the random
variable
w1 and or integrable w2 that
has the following nice property namely
if you look at the difference between w1
and w2
you compute its variance well you're
obviously going to get the variance of
w1
the variance of w2 and here's where the
joint distribution comes in these two
quantities obviously just depending on
the marginals
but the joint distribution comes in
through the covariance between w1 and w2
you want to make the variance of w as
small as possible
which means that you want to make this
covariance between w1 and w2
as large as possible you want to
correlate this to be
as big as possible and this again
involves choosing a
suitable joint distribution that
induces as much correlation as much
positive correlation
as possible so this is unlike the
control various contexts where you've
got various
reductions for both negative and
positive correlations in this setting
you really need the
correlation to be strong and positive
so here's a you know a setting where
it's
relatively easy to do so imagine that w1
and w2
are monotone functions of some input
randomness c one through c d
where the uh f tilde one function and
that tilde two functions are both
monotone in the same direction
okay in other words if you look at f
tilde
i as a function of its d coordinates
the f delta i's are monotony in each of
the different coordinate
variables so the f delta eyes are
monotone in that sense
then there's a general theorem having to
do with
uh what are called associated random
variables that w1 and w2
are guaranteed of a positive covariance
in that case and as a consequence
you get a guaranteed efficiency
improvement in this context
so this is a setting where
uh you have to be creative in terms of
finding
a coupling finding a joint distribution
that induces as much positive
correlation as possible
and again in settings where
you can do this effectively this can
provide quite significant variance
reductions and looking
at differences of expected values so
you know intuitively it makes sense that
you get a very introduction by doing
this at some
level by uh
subjecting w1 and w2 to exactly the same
input randomness
this is fairer to to the two systems
if one system is unlucky enough to get
some bad cis that may get small
that uh same set of random variables c
one through c
d will also make w two small so they'll
both simultaneously be
lower than average and uh you won't get
any sort of quote-unquote unfair
comparisons between w1 and w2
so it makes sense intuitively that
inducing this type of
correlation would generate a variance
reduction
okay next algorithm is important
sampling
so suppose we want to compute the
expected value of w
in many contexts we have the
opportunity to potentially
use a different sampling distribution in
q by
uh modifying the underlying probability
distribution
p uh in particular let's say multiply
and divide through by the
density of p with respect to q this
would be the so-called
likelihood ratio that i'm denoting here
as an element good
and then we can write this p expected
value in terms of q expected value in
which
uh w is now multiplied by l l
is a likelihood random variable that
basically measures the corresponding
likelihood
of a given omega under p
to that under q that's why it's called a
likelihood
ratio in the world of statistics
so with this identity in place we can
now search for
a value of q that for a choice of q
that makes the variance of uh
this estimator of the expected value as
small as possible
and uh there is in fact is a zero
variance choice
in the case that the random variable w
is non-negative
turns out in that case if i just choose
the likelihood ratio or equivalently if
i choose q
to have the following likelihood ratio
namely
to make l star equal to w
over alpha then
uh you actually get a
uh output random variable w times l
which is equal to
uh don't quite have this correct
maybe the other area should be alpha
over w
and then if you take w times l star we
see that we just get alpha back again
that's a deterministic quantity namely
expected value we're trying to compute
this is another situation where we get
zero variance
so just as in the control variance
context
this is a setting where uh it's
unrealistic
to expect that you can ever implement
this zero variance algorithm
uh in practice that of course just as in
the previous context you hope to use a
distribution q tilde that at least
approximates q star
and where many algorithms have been
successfully built
exactly on that kind of principle using
the ideas of importance sampling
in particular in the world of rare
events in relation important sampling
turns out to be a very very
powerful method in getting potentially
enormous variance reductions
for rare event probabilities
now let me just illustrate this
important sampling idea in the context
of markov chains
suppose that we want to compute the
expected reward associated with the
state of america
chain at time n uh
the the natural
uh importance distribution qdus would be
one
under which the dynamics of x will
continue to be
determined by a markov chain so
effectively
replace the transition matrix p by a
transition matrix
q and use q dynamics to run the mark
option rather than p dynamics and when
you do that
you get a likelihood ratio that is just
uh the product of
the uh p transition probabilities for a
given path divided by the product of the
q transition
probabilities for the same path so that
the product of the numerator numerator
probabilities is just the
product of that path associated with the
p distribution
and similarly the product of the few
probabilities in the denominator
is just the relative likelihood of that
sample path under the queued analytics
now it turns out the variance
of this type of uh likelihood ratio
deteriorates quite badly as a function
of the time horizon
m in fact it increases geometrically or
exponentially
than m but an important thing to
recognize or maybe a surprising thing to
recognize is that if you look at
the ln itself
and easiest way to look at ln as well in
the world of probability
it's sums of random variables are the
easiest to analyze because
we have laws and large numbers in
central limit theorem so ln is a product
but if we take the log of ln we do get a
sum
so if we take log of ln we get a sum of
quantities involving the path
dynamics of the markov chain divided by
n
and we're going to be basically looking
at a lot of large numbers for markov
chains laws of large numbers from marcos
chains
[Music]
apply in great generality and uh
what one sees is that you end up with a
entropy type
limit in which the uh this
entropy quantity is less than zero
now what's that saying it's saying the
log of ln divided by
n converges to a limit that is less than
zero
and of course that's basically saying
that ln decays to zero
exponentially fast in n
so not only does ln go to zero q almost
surely
others when you apply the dynamics of q
but it even goes to zero exponentially
fast in the end
so ln is going to zero exponentially
fast but up here
the variance of ln is exploding to
infinity exponentially fast so
that's a an uh a bit of a strange
dichotomy there but of course that's
consistent with the following type of
situation that
if you look at the density function
associated with this likelihood ratio
it's when n is large it's accumulating a
lot of mass
near zero but of course in order for the
variance to be
big it must be that there's some
probability mass out of some very large
value
that makes the variance of ln go to
infinity exponentially in
n so this is a situation where
the likelihood ratio is very heavy
tailed
and as a consequence
important sampling has a following very
unpleasant characteristic
namely your introduction can work very
effectively
in many settings but there are also many
settings for the
important sampling can look to the naked
eye
like it is behaving very well and what
do i mean by look to the negative pi
before in the sample variance estimate
and what happens when you form the
sample variance estimate well you're
mostly sampling from this part of the
distribution
and the likelihood quantities that
you're sampling from are all close
together
all close to zero so as a consequence
the sample variance estimate
you get is very small
and as a consequence the sample
variances that you get for the important
sampling algorithm look very small
which means you say to yourself this is
great i'm getting a big variance
reduction
but in fact uh what could
very well be happening is that you have
a disaster occurring because
you just haven't sampled these pieces
and
those are pieces that could be quite
fundamentally important
to the expectation that you're actually
trying to compute
so when variance when important sampling
fails it fails in the worst possible way
namely the standard sample based
diagnostic that would use to determine
whether an
algorithm is behaving poorly or not the
so-called
standard sample variance estimate that
also goes to pieces
in the problems where important sampling
tends to behave the worst
so you have to be very careful of
applying important sampling ideas to
problems in which the time
horizon and as large
i should mention that
you um might imagine based on the fact
that
uh you know when you look at one plus
condition over n to the nth power this
is
looking for a large n like e to the c
this is all something we
we know now where is this something like
this coming up something like this is
coming up basically when we look at the
likelihood ratio
um you might imagine based on this
analysis that
you need q and p if you want to avoid
this exponential increase in the
uh into variance
you want to choose p and q relatively
close to one another so you don't want
to have a
p q being a large perturbation away from
p
and you might say to yourself well this
analysis suggests that q
and p have to be perturbed away from one
another by an amount
of order one over n turns out you can
actually use a
one over root n uh perturbation
and you still get the fact that the
likelihood ratio
uh when you perturb in that life no
longer blows up exponentially but is
well behaved
even for large time horizons again
and the reason that uh this one over
root n works rather than whatever n has
to do with the fact that uh
the likelihood ratio is again a
martingale and there's
something related to some behavior that
was uh
coming out of the martingale central
limit limiter and is
controlling the cycle fluctuations of
the likelihood ratio
um there are a number of questions
so one of the questions is
okay so what does this all mean so
if you want to use important sampling
what would be the recommendation how do
you
determine the horizon after which we
shouldn't even attempt to
apply it wow
[Music]
i think what what this analysis says is
that you have to have your eyes open
when you apply important sampling and
you know you can do various things to
[Music]
try to control these bad fluctuations
now when you do that you're also going
to limit the degree of variance
reduction that the variance reduction
technique might
have otherwise uh given to you
so for example you know and
you know you would see one diagnostic
one thing you can certainly do
that can often help is
likelihood ratios must have the property
if we look back at this identity
i put w equal to one on the left hand
side and the right hand side
and i see of course on the left hand
side i get one on the right hand side i
get expected value of
l under q so i know
that expected value of the likelihood
ratio under the q measure
is one so if i
am doing using important sampling and i
find out that my
the average of my likelihood ratios
is close to one that's a good thing that
means i probably
even if i'm in a situation as i see here
where most of the mass of the likelihood
ratio is close to zero
it must be that the uh i've done enough
sampling
with my uh important sampling
distribution just seeing some of these
observations out in the tail so that
would mean
that i've got a large enough sample size
of importance experiments that i've done
that
i've seen some of this stuff and now i
think in that situation
you would worry much less about these
sample variances and things of that kind
of very likely
that the sample variance is then going
to be a reliable
estimate of the true population variance
if you're seeing this type of behavior
if you see the sample average l bar is
not close to one that's probably again
a very strong indicator that
you haven't yet seen this part of the
tail
and that the sample variance estimate
that you have is potentially misleading
in fact i suspect that this is like a
one-sided test
right that if you're seeing that the
sample average is far from
one then you can be sure that something
is
fishy whereas if you see that the sample
average is one then maybe other things
can still be fishy it's just you're
lucky somehow
well it feels like that i totally
i think in many problems what you said
is correct but it wouldn't always be the
case because uh
there would be problems for example that
this can happen in the rear event
simulation context
there would be settings where uh
the w may have support on a part of the
probability space and part of the sample
space
where this doesn't occur where you don't
actually have this this big
piece out in the tail so it could be
that the event for example you try to
compute a rare event probability for
is an event where the likelihood ratio
is uniformly well
controlled and all of those values are
actually down here
so that you actually get an extremely
big variance reduction
and that in fact is what happens in a
typically successful
rare event simulation context was that's
exactly
what occurs is uh the likelihood the
part of the
the part of the likelihood ratio where
the
uh expected value is uh
where it's big that makes expecting that
equal to one uh just
uh has no intersection with the event
that you're actually trying to complete
a
probability
yeah okay gotcha so uh this one-sided
idea
is also imperfect in a way even if you
uh see a big deviation with a bar
uh it may not matter because you may be
lucky uh
right i think it depends a lot on the
type of you know if you're trying to
compute so for example expected
uh long run reward and you decide to use
important sampling to try to estimate
that
that would be a situation i think for
your
diagnostic your one-sided perspective
would be more uh accurate in that
setting than in the rare events in
relation context
uh awesome and so when you're talking
about this controlling q and p
to be close uh to each other uh what are
the methods that people would use with
particle filtering
someone asked would particle filtering
be one of the methods that
could uh you know like make you adapt
uh the sampling distributions to that
like
uh this quantity is controlled uh
i haven't seen particle filtering
applied to do this
and there would be
but it is the case that that particle
type methods
can be quite efficient in some settings
where
important sampling is also potentially
effective
so for example again in the rare event
simulation context
would be the case that uh
sometimes it's actually better to apply
a method called
splitting and splitting is at some level
basically a particle method
for doing rare event simulation so
i like the idea of thinking about
particles
i'm not sure if i've seen it in exactly
a context where it's been
i think that they did have some
some idea monte carlo but maybe i'm
mixing this up
uh with particle filters uh some
i don't know anyways um it's all good
uh thanks okay great so i'm just gonna
continue i'm gonna
can i take a few more minutes let's see
if it's fine
so i just want to say a bit about
gradient estimation
and uh
so we all know that there are many
settings in which you want to compute
gradients
and it's important to sort of recognize
that there are two ways that
gradients can occur in these integration
problems one is the performance measure
w
depends explicitly on the uh
parameter that you want to compute a
gradient for the other case is that
the parameter appears in the probability
measure or probability distribution p
theta and uh
an important thing to recognize is that
uh oftentimes
you have the ability to move dependence
and p
theta into the w thetas
and uh and reverse as well so for
example in the case of normal
random variables uh we can
imagine dependence and let's say the
mean
as either being represented for example
in the
probability density function underlying
normal random variable
that would correspond to the dependence
on the mean parameter let's say mu
setting sitting in the p theta the other
thing that you can do
is you know that normal random variables
can be realized
uh with the mean sitting again as a
location parameter so take a normal 0
1 and add mu onto that that
is another way of representing a normal
with
a with a mean u
and when you push out the dependence
into the random variable itself that
would mean that
you're sort of looking at parametric
dependence and w
of theta now computing gradients is of
importance in the context of stochastic
gradient descent
it's also important in the context of uh
statistical analysis where you're trying
to
understand uh the sensitivity of your
the poor performance of your system to
statistical uncertainty and underlying
model communities
so
when the parametric dependence sits in
the w of theta
uh we can just bring the gradient inside
and uh hopefully interchange the
derivative expected value
we can do a similar thing in the context
of parametric dependence on
in the probability distribution p theta
in that case uh we would apply the
important sampling idea that we
discussed earlier to represent
the p theta distribution in terms of the
q distribution q distribution this
context would be the
uh p distribution setting up parameter
point theta nut
and now we have a representation of
alpha theta in terms of the expected
value of parameter point theta not this
would be
like the expected value under q that
we're looking at earlier in the
important sampling context
times w times the likelihood ratio now
of course the likelihood ratio depends
on the parameter
theta that's how we end up with this
representation
now again you can just interchange or
hopefully just interchange
the gradient and the expected value i
should say
a little bit here that in general the
conditions under which you can
interchange the expected value in the
gradient
uh those conditions are are
very very weak in the setting of
this interchange so it's almost always
the case
that this limit interchange is valid
it's not it's it's not anywhere near as
often the case
that you can interchange the gradient
with the expected value and the
parametric dependence is sitting in the
w
all right so um
let me now talk about the application to
markov chains
uh suppose that we want to compute a
gradient of an expected value
corresponding to a steady state
reward so think about x infinity is
having the steady state distribution
r is the word function i want to compute
the expected value
of the reward under parameter choice
theta
and in this case the natural w would be
just the time average
reward that i get from simulating the
first n steps of the markov chain that
should be
a good estimate of r of x infinity
and now uh the
natural uh estimator based on
the likelihood ratio idea
would be to represent the gradient in
terms of w
times the gradient of the likelihood
ratio and the gradient of the liquid
ratio
is easily computable in this context
and now again there's a very nice thing
that we observe in this setting because
the likelihood ratio itself was a
martingale
it had turned out it's a mean one
martingale
the gradient of the likelihood ratio
turns out to be another mining hill
and uh this thing actually has mean
drill so
the fact that this thing is a mean zero
mining gale by the way this of course
is suggesting based on our discussion
earlier that this thing can be used as a
control area
so we'll come back to that in a moment
i'm not going to go through the details
in this slide because we're
short of time so let me just say that
uh the um that
when the the w
gradient estimator so that style of
computing gradients would be
known within the discrete event
simulation community as infinitesimal
perturbation analysis ipa
so in this setting
ipa of the medical perturbation analysis
has an error
that decreases our rate 1 over square
root of n so in other words the standard
canonical convergence rate for monte
carlo
namely errors go down at rate one over
square root
when you apply the likelihood ratio idea
the errors are much much larger
that's the case that likely ratio
methods would be
applicable in much greater generality
but
uh along with that greater applicability
comes much larger variances and you can
sort of see that through this last
line i'm not going to go through the
derivation you can easily follow
roughly speaking what i've done uh in
these
first two lines but the key thing that
you can see here
is that the rather than the error going
down right one over root n the error is
actually
increasing at rate square root of n
which is pretty
not too good um
now you see that the pre-multiplier in
front of the brood n
involves the expected uh reward
this obviously goes away if respective
reward is zero
one thing that you might think about
doing is try to
set up a problem so that the expected
reward is indeed zero
and you might think about doing that by
working with instead of working with the
reward function itself try to work with
a standard version of the reward
function so that this thing would indeed
have been zero
and this thing would go away and you'd
end up with a
uh variability to this estimator that
still wouldn't be
going to zero at the canonical rate but
at least the variability would be
of order one and that would
suggest that then by replicating this
estimator multiple times that you could
then
get a consistent estimator for the
gradient
by just doing some super replications of
this quantity
independently multiple times let's say m
of them
and by averaging those n things you'd
get
uh gradient estimate that would have a
stochastic variability of order one over
square root of m
so that then is in the realm of
something that uh is
practically doable and
you can see that uh
if you do indeed do what i just
suggested that you get
improved performance and the
improved performance that i was hinting
at
uh effectively is equivalent to using
the fact that the
uh that this
gradient is a zero knee martingale which
means that you can represent it in terms
of martingale differences
that's the dis that i have here and
then apply martingale central limit
ideas to
obtain the limiting approximations that
are on these slides
so likely ratio gradient estimators can
be
successfully used in many different
contexts but they do typically have
significantly larger variability than to
the ipa estimates in settings when ipa
and lightweight ratio methods both uh
are applicable another alternative
method of course is to
not try to go for computing the gradient
but to use a finite difference
approximation
they typically would converge
significantly slower than what the
likelihood ratio of gradient estimates
that i was just describing
when you apply finite differences one
thing to be aware of is
just as in the world of deterministic uh
numerical calculation when you want to
compute derivatives or gradients you
always do better by
using central difference approximations
rather than forward difference or
backward difference approximations
so you can
just a very quick uh sense
of what happens in this context
the natural finite difference
approximation would be if you want to
compute the performance
or the gradient of let's say the point
theta naught the derivative at the point
theta nut
i do some simulations of theta naught
plus h simulations at point theta naught
minus h
that's central differences divide by 2h
and then because of the central
differences the second derivative
term in the error gets knocked out in
particular when you do a
taylor approximation of the expected
values corresponding to this piece and
this piece
and now you get a contribution from the
third derivative
of order h squared a lot of order h as
would have occurred if you'd applied
forward differences
there's the random error
the optimal choice of difference
increment is an order
n to the minus one sixth so you can use
a pretty big
difference increment because of the fact
that you're doing central differences
and as a factor of the fact that you can
choose an
h that's big that means the quantity
that you're dividing through here and
the denominator is relatively large
not small but this thing we're small
that really blows up the variance
that gives you convergence rate of n to
the minus one third
and if you then did some obvious common
random number synchronizations of the
random numbers that you simulate at
theta naught plus
h are closely synchronized with those at
the point theta naught plus
h then in significant generality at
least in the context of discrete event
simulation type objects you've got a
convergence rate that is
better than just using central
differences we've got a conversion rate
of n or minus two fifths which is now
getting
somewhat close to the canonical square
root rate
all right so um
i'm not going to cover these last two
slides in stochastic optimization you
can just read that for yourself
let me just conclude by saying that the
simulation literature in the monte carlo
literature is an enormous literature
a lot of carlos applied to pretty much
every uh
area of engineering every area of the
sciences
even some are the social sciences
economics etc
different fields construct
somewhat different uh methodologies
depending on the class of models that
they typically work with
and so you can find a vast array of
interesting and different
ideas that people applied in which they
have
[Music]
uh taking advantage of problem structure
associated with the models that go with
their own particular
domain area and have creatively
uh used uh that problem structure to
generate uh powerful
efficiency improvement techniques that
leverage
that structure there are lots of things
i haven't covered in today's lectures
and i'm not going to
mention them at this point but you can
find some discussion of these things in
the book that i wrote with solan asmason
you can go look at the winter simulation
conference that's a
major conference for people that work in
the simulation
area and there's an acm journal that is
devoted to
simulation as well so all of those
places are
good places to read up and simulation
and it's various uh
research uh suburbs so thank you very
much for listening to me this afternoon
and
if you have any further questions we'll
be happy to take them at this point
thank you
very nice talk of course it's really
hard to
uh give an overview of all
all the designs that uh
exist in this uh huge literature i guess
uh
but uh i think that i i i don't know
personally uh i really like this this
overview
uh it gave us a glimpse into
uh the way people are approaching these
problems
so one of the big differences that seems
to
be true or seems to
appear between how machine learning
people
are thinking about similar problems
whereas this
uh what we see here is is this
distinct and phases or lack of fan
phases on the part of machine learning
people and asymptotics right
um so we know that a lot of times
the asymptotics is going to be very
useful
but there are also cases when the
asymptotics is kind of
dangerous uh do you have some high-level
thoughts about how to think about this
uh how important it is to think about
uh the non-assimilate cases finite time
and releases
uh this is the especially uh i guess
interesting if you're trying to come up
is you know general arguments for
some classes of problems that would
adapt to the structure of the problem
and you really care about the
finite sample performance uh
um is that is that something that people
are uh interested in in the simulation
community or
or is this on a fringe or uh
uh you know i think that uh you know the
simulation community also is being
influenced by people's
interests on hard error advance
as associated with some areas of machine
learning for example
but you know it is the case probably
that most people would take the view
that you know if you had approached
something like
the construction of confidence in
results let's imagine the very first
community that had gotten into that
was a community that was very focused on
finite
time devs that's probably the case maybe
arguably the case
that uh maybe all of this theory having
to do
with the use of a normal approximation
would
not have gotten developed to an
appreciable degree because
that theory does not come with good
finite
sample guarantees
there are things called the berry essene
theorem and edgeworth expansion various
other things that
are suggestive of what happens for
finite sample size but
those uh you know the the very essence
there in particular which gives me rates
and conversions for the central limit
theorem
there's no way to get a uh
a error rate on the central limit term
without having
information about effectively higher
moments of a random variable in the
variance
now you need to know something about
let's say the third moment
of the random variable or the two plus
adult moment of the random variable
and uh you know as as i was saying
earlier
um you know
you you would have access to that in the
bounded place
even in the bounded case once you're
outside the bernoulli setting you
probably begin getting very very
conservative estimates
if you look at the worst two plus delta
moment
over let's say a random variable it's
bounded between minus c
and plus c
i guess raises the question of how
the degree of adaptivity that you can
achieve if you're constructing this
finite simple bonds right
because i agree with you that like if
you focus on the verse
is then worst case bonds
across the board uh tend to be
really conservative of course if their
worst case optima that you can't even
improve upon them
right uh in the worst case setting so if
you take you know bonded uh
random variables then hovering is
optimal you can't improve up on it
in the worst case sense but of course
it's going to be conservative it's
misses
like big things being comes along
uh answers the first the question is
like how far can you push this
and and i guess maybe the question is
like how
like is would is this something
that people worry about or or would
think
would be useful to dive more into or
or people for some reason believe that
the asymptotic
uh really captures uh
the essential aspects of the problems
in a way uh
so i'll just i can't speak on behalf of
the entire community i can only speak on
my own behalf
i guess probably some feelings i would
say
that again just going back to this i
think the confidence interval
methodologies that are based on normal
approximations are
generally viewed as being extremely
useful
at both a practical level and
theoretical level
and there are uh you know diagnostics
that you can do
that sort of are indicative of uh
situations in which you might
you would have some sense that maybe the
normal approximation is not going to
is not working well in this particular
context for example if you just
look at uh the sample skewness or sample
kurtosis from a sample
and you see that they
are significantly different from what
you see in a normal population
that would be indicative of the fact
that
uh probably the normal approximation and
the
confidence rule based on final
approximation you're probably not
going to be doing well for relatively
small sample size in particular maybe
the sample size that
you've used and you know you see for
example if you bootstrap
the confidence interval instead that you
get significantly different confidence
intervals than what you get from the
asymptotic three
so there are there are sample based
things that you can do
that do give you information about small
sample
problems that you may be seeing and
applying the asymptotic theory
i think that when you look at what
statisticians would typically do that
would be their typical
answer to those types of problems are
well aware
of the fact that there are
issues that arise in small sample
settings that
cast doubt on very limited theory
it's probably one of the first things
that everyone learns about after the
central immigrant right
exactly so but you know people would
look probably more
for statistic for diagnostics that you
can see
from the sample on the world of
statistics they really have no choice
uh they're going to do that because
you know they don't know anything about
the underlying population so they can't
assume
that they have uh let's say bounded that
they have a
uh a bound of 100 let's say on the
population of reals
but there's no way for status quo
you're thinking about average height of
people then you can
say that okay by what you limit the
highest well
that's yeah you're right that's an okay
context where you can say
there are settings where things are
bounded but yeah even in those settings
then you can begin
arguing do i really have an iid sample
or not in the population
sure yeah yeah
true uh the world of monte carlo is a
setting where in principle
we can verify all of these hypotheses we
in principle do know what the
variance is what you know right
bound things as we wish
so there is a there is some difference
between the monte carlo setting
and the statistics setting but i think
probably
what i said a moment ago i think would
still be accurate probably most people
who do practical monte carlo
that's arguable about whether i'm in
that group or not but to the extent that
you look at people that that really are
using monofilament practical level
i think most of the things that they
would do would not be based on
finite and theory most of what they
would do would be based on looking at
the sample that comes up in monoclonal
experiment and doing some
adaptation based on that
okay thank you uh so there's a question
uh from uh
gargu uh is the slow rate for finite
difference gradient estimators
inherent are there any lower bounds for
this family of estimators
you know you mentioned the n to the
minus one third and to the minus two
fifths
uh yeah i think i haven't
thought about that but my guess is that
there are inherent bills
uh yeah
that's a good question uh
yeah you can think about the family of
uh functions uh
obviously it should be some smooth
family of functions
and then you want some kind of
estimator that is based on finite
differences and then the bias variance
should be resolved in some way and like
the question is how does it resolve
i guess i think if you're only allowed
to do function evaluations you have no
access to radians
along the lines of the likelihood ratio
of gradient estimator but everything has
to be
based on function evaluations only uh
uh quite confident that there would be
reasonable
interest in lower bounds
and i'm sure that they would coincide
with what we see in this degree
okay that's interesting i
i find a question quite fascinating
um yeah
uh sean is shown yesterday gave a talk
where he was talking about
uh quasi stochastic approximations uh
he he seems to be a little bit obsessed
with that uh
do you wanna say a few words about it i
think
it is also related to quasi-monte carlo
i guess
and uh so i guess in his talk he was
emphasizing that
um quasi uh stochastic approximation
uh that you're replacing the noise that
would go into
uh let's say you have some simulation
based on which you run your stochastic
approximation algorithm
rather than inducing noise there uh you
induce some you know periodic signal
or something like that that has some
nice ergodicity property
and lo and behold you find that
convergence rate do
improve um so that was a major point
uh in uh in his lecture
uh i don't know what he wants me to ask
though like he sent the message
but uh that's an interesting
uh i apologize i should have done that
in hiding
it just it just with uh kefir wolfowitz
with like sine waves
you can actually you get one over t for
the
with bias you know with the epsilon
squared bias
for smooth functions and then um
in order to get no
no bias i there would be a loss and i
don't really know yet how much
but um but i don't know why you would
use white noise
for stochastic optimization if it's if
you have full control of the noise that
was
that was really my point it wasn't
really a question okay well i guess
maybe
to the lower bounds right uh
that if you only have this point
evaluation property then
maybe a deterministic method is actually
going to do better
than if you're just using some noise
yeah in terms of estimating gradients
i guess there it's it's like uh with
maximum seeking
uh and then there you saw the
the advantage uh i i don't know whether
it
uh you can see the same advantage shown
uh just estimating the gradient
excuse me uh so the advantage
in maximum seeking that came from this
quasi-random point of view
is it can it be traced back to
just uh the variance reduction uh
uh with spain it's a different culture
of the
extreme seeking control the literature
was just like a
a completely i don't think that many of
the people they didn't know about kiefer
wolf
when they developed that theory and i'm
not sure
you know um if we were maybe the first
to point out that
they were related i don't i don't know
i'm still trying to work out the history
but there was it was like two different
it was like another planet the
extremists you can control
right i guess
this classy random input would uh like
you can
see them as improving the quality of the
gradient estimates
and that's why
yeah i mean that's after the fact for
sure that's why i mean basically
like a sine wave sine cosine is a markov
process but with covariance zero
and so uh you lose some terms when you
do the
the rate analysis so it's um so you know
any markup process
with zero uh asymptotic covariance would
be a big improvement on using ied
exploration that's that's really what it
is and
just and so you do that why you do the
same analysis you do for a stochastic
approximation
um but yeah so i wonder what you get if
you really want zero
um bias i don't you probably don't get
one of a t
but it's a lot faster than one of the
two to the
um again we have to wrap up because uh
we are quite a bit over time and we are
uh
starting to grab the time of the next
talk uh so
um thank you thank you peter again uh
very nice to have you uh very much
enjoyed uh the talk
uh and uh if we are looking for the
final versions of the slides later
um and uh keep in touch
i will thanks for all the great
questions everyone